a lot has changed in real life since I
first started playing New Horizons at
the end of February and even since I
wrote my review in progress in the
middle of March having such a wholesome
game during an objectively bad time has
been something of a blessing for a lot
of people myself included and I'd be
lying if I said it hasn't affected how I
play New Horizons I find myself turning
to the game at night when I can't sleep
or during the day when I'm stressed and
I need a break
we're often than not an adorable
villager or even just a sense of
accomplishment from finishing my chores
will cheer me up
but that alone is not what defines new
horizon the times I go to the game when
I'm in a good mood are just as important
as the times I'm seeking comfort even if
I end the day anxious I wake up excited
to see what's new in my island I can't
wait to see who's visiting for the day
to check out the bridge I just build to
the new flowers that might be growing or
how my new decor looks in the daytime
and I look forward to playing with my
friends trading items and design ideas
and hitting each other with Nets New
Horizons inspires creative
self-expression and embraces kindness
and friendship and that is really what
makes it such a joy
[Music]
the first few days in New Horizons are
all about establishing the basics of any
other Animal Crossing town like the
Museum into me and Tommy store and this
sets the stage for the new crafting
system in addition to catching fish and
bugs and picking fruit to make money you
also have to spend a good chunk of time
at the start gathering resources to
craft the furniture a question of you
and in one case to build a whole
building because I wanted to unlock and
upgrade things as quickly as possible
I spent hours each day for the first
three or four days running around
picking weeds chopping trees for wood
shaking the same trees for branches
hitting rocks for clay stone and iron
and selling whatever I couldn't use to
craft for some extra bells it was a bit
overwhelming at first to do all that in
the name of fast checking my island
progression but generally crafting fits
neatly into animal Crossing's
established daily shores loop the act of
gathering resources happens
simultaneously with the other things I
want to do each day and actually makes
those tasks more lucrative than they
were in previous games for example I
shake my trees because two of them per
day dropped furniture instead of fruit
or branches and the branches I do get
are a bonus in my search because of this
I don't really have to go out of my way
to get the resources I need to craft
furniture tools and the other items I
want
[Music]
you start out with an assortment of
crafting recipes and you can get new
ones in a variety of ways that like
resource gathering are a natural
extension of the existing Animal
Crossing formula you can buy some of
them find new ones most days washed up
in the beach or get them from your
neighbors among other methods finding a
new recipe is an exciting reward for
going about your day because crafting
goes beyond furniture and tools I found
some surprising and creative recipes
using ingredients I didn't expect
complementing all of this is the nick
miles program which is based off real
life travel rewards points
look miles are a separate currency you
can use to buy special items and
abilities like new hairstyles and colors
you can switch to at a mirror you can
even use Knick miles to pay off your
first loan and get a real house you get
Nick miles for doing all sorts of things
from getting stung by a wasp to catching
100 fish in a row without failing once
you can also get Nick miles for shaking
furniture from trees which if you're
counting is the second extra reward you
can get just from doing that the Nick
mile system adds just enough direction
if you aren't sure what to do without
being overbearing I've only felt the
need to chase the particularly difficult
Nick miles achievements like the fishing
one I've gotten most of my Nick miles
just by doing animal crossing things and
having a nice time and even though I
spend some every day I still have tons
to spare while the day-to-day is rich
with things to do overall progression is
a bit slow it took a frustrating 33 days
for nook's cranny to upgrade where in
previous games it would take around 10
and there are buildings and characters
like Brewster and the roost there are
total emia right now this may be due at
least in part to Nintendo's live service
approach to New Horizons in which
certain events and characters come to
the game via free update throughout the
year there's definitely potential for
more of the series cast of characters to
appear over time but currently it's
disappointing that so many of them are
absent in the mean time it's all too
easy to absorb yourself in customization
and self-expression this starts with
your character you can actually choose
your appearance for the first time in
the series including skin colour and
none of the options are locked to gender
all hairstyles and clothing options are
available to anyone and you can change
your face and hair at any time dressing
up is further improved by a dedicated
outfit menu that lets you preview a full
outfit rather than switching in and out
of clothes until you find something you
like it has never been easier or more
enjoyable to express yourself through
your characters appearance in an animal
crossing game and I've been having a ton
of fun trying on goofy outfits and
changing my hair to match just because
crafting is naturally a big part of
customization you can't craft everything
some kinds of furniture are only
available in the shop or found randomly
but there are entire sets of furniture
that can only be crafted and those are
largely the pieces that you can further
customize with different colors and
finishes at first I crafted whatever
pieces I needed but hadn't been able to
buy like a mirror but I ended up styling
an entire room around furniture I'd
crafted and customized more importantly
you can now place the furniture pretty
much anywhere outside this allows you to
create parks or playgrounds or sitting
areas or anything else you can think of
around your island which is both fun
creatively and a great way to make your
desertedisland feel like a real
community and then there's island
designer new horizons brand new
terraforming feature with it you can
completely redesign the water features
and Hills of your island which lends you
an almost intimidating level of creative
freedom in your island lay out the tools
for water scaping and cliff construction
are a bit tricky to use and masters
since it can be hard to gauge where
exactly your character will build or
destroy something but it's a powerful
creative tool overall you can also
create paths plazas flower beds and more
and it's a huge improvement on the
equivalent in past Animal Crossing games
since paths are easy to place and
impossible to remove on accident animals
will even stick to any paths you put
down and walking around which is just
one of the little details that make them
more lively and endearing I haven't
stopped what I'm doing just to watch a
villager do their thing
[Music]
animals will drink tea or stargaze or
try to catch bugs and some of them will
put on reading glasses to read books at
home you can even run into them at the
museum and they'll comment on the
exhibits each of these details gives
dimension to villagers where their
limited personality types and phrases
might fall short and it's easy to fall
in love with them outside of how cute
villagers can be New Horizons is just
beautiful to look at the Museum in
particular blew me away the exhibits are
incredibly detailed and walking through
each of them genuinely feels like
walking through a real museum the
following for example has lines along
the floor that seemed to chart
evolutionary lines for different animals
following those lines takes you from one
display to the next and at some points
the camera will even pan to get you a
better view of what's on display the
cherry on top is sharing all of this
with friends my friends and I trade
items and tips and give each other spare
crafting recipes I went on a museum date
with my partner just like one we'd been
on in real life a year ago the joy to
visit friends and see how they've
decorated their islands each time I
visit someone I leave with a new idea
for my own island and we all send each
other letters and gifts in the game
because right now at least we can't see
each other in real life New Horizons has
a slower pace even than other Animal
Crossing games and at times that can
feel unnecessarily restrictive but
there's still plenty to do and each of
those activities feeds into the next
brilliantly for a rewarding and
relentlessly cheerful experience New
Horizons certainly came at the right
time and its strengths are particularly
comforting right now I'm as excited to
see what random events await me each
morning as I am glad to have it during
hard times and that's sure to keep me
coming back for the foreseeable future
[Music]